this video is brought to you by squarespace
whether it's your new profession or just a
lifelong passion star your journey to website
glory with squarespace check out their amazing
all-in-one platform through the link in
the description below more on them in a bit
in the cruel and callous world of feudal japan
the harsh reality was that toyotomi hideyoshi
was born in nobody he had no
samurai lineage to speak of
he was supposed to be just another nameless
grunt who did the bidding of his lord we
weren't even supposed to remember his name yet
alone demon-worthy enough of a biographics video
yet here we are and right from the beginning
we get to the heart of what made toyotomi so
special he was born a peasant and everyone
expected him to die the same way since
upward mobility was an almost alien concept
in feudal japan but hideyoshi was intelligent
shrewd and hardworking and he made perfect use of
all of his skills attaining a status considered
unthinkable for someone of his station he is now
remembered as one of japan's three great unifiers
toyotomi she was born circa 1536 in the village
of nakamura in the awari province just a quick
reminder using japanese naming conventions
toyotomi was the surname while hideyoshi was the
given name although he wasn't actually called this
until decades later when he founded his own clan
but for simplicity's stake we're going to use it
from the beginning to make things less confusing
his birth name was hiyoshi and he was the son
of kinoshita yeymun a farmer who also served as
an ashigaru a foot soldier from the lower classes
who did all of the military work that was unworthy
of a samurai one of the downsides of being born a
peasant apart from the miserable living conditions
back breaking labor and short life expectancy
was that nobody considered you important enough
to write down your history which means that
the first part of toyotomi's life is one
big old question mark one thing that we are
familiar with though is the violent and bloody
world that he grew up in the warring states or
sengoku period of japan by that point the power
structure in japan had fractured completely there
was still an emperor and a shogun but neither one
wielded sufficient authority to unite the entire
country under their rule instead power had been
disseminated among dozens of lords known as
daimyo who had spent the last hundred years
or so fighting with each other it seemed that
japan was destined to carry on like this forever
if not for the efforts of toyotomi hirayoshi and
the two other great unifiers oda nobunaga and
tokugawa leiasu one thing that the sengoku period
did was create a constant demand for military work
if growing vegetables wasn't your thing
and you weren't good at crafting anything
then the nearest daimyo always had a need for
an extra body to arm and fling at his rival the
pay was usually better than that of a farmer
and there was also the chance of promotion so
it's not surprising that many saw this as their
best career option given that his father served
as an ashigaru it made sense for hiyoshi to
follow in his footsteps in 1551 when he was
around 15 years old he enrolled in the army of
a daimyo named imagawa yoshimotu this was an
unusual move because it would have made more
sense for hideyoshi to join the oda clan not
only was it the clan that ruled over his native
awari province but it was also where his father
had served as an ashigaro but who knows what
hideyoshi's motivations were back then ashigaru
were moroccan to mercenaries who were only in it
for the money and were quick to change allegiances
so maybe he thought that imagawa had a better
shot of coming out on top even so after a few
years in his army had a yoshi had a change of
heart and in 1558 he left him against employ
and joined the odor clan which at that point was
ruled by the ruthless and ambitious oda nobunaga
if you want an in-depth look at nobunaga's role
in the unification of japan you can check out
our biographics video that we did on him a while
back basically he first fought his relatives for
leadership of the oda clan and once he triumphed
he set his sights on the whole of japan which
basically involved fighting all the other major
clans one by one we're not sure what role toyotomi
assumed in obanaga's clan but he certainly did
not start out at the top some sources suggested
that hideyoshi was a construction supervisor who
oversaw the repair of one of naga's castles or a
fuel supervisor who made sure that all the various
camps were adequately supplied with firewood the
most fanciful tale claimed that hideyoshi served
as nobunaga's sandal-bearer which historically
was a pretty important position since it always
kept the servant in proximity to his lord whatever
roles toyotomi might have fulfilled it seems
that he impressed nobunaga with his diligence
and hard work there is one story probably made
up of nobunaga waking up very early one bitterly
cold morning and taking a walk through his castle
to find that everyone was still sleeping soundly
wrapped up nice and snug in their warm beds
everyone except for hiyoshi that is who had
already woken up and started working this kind
of dedication brought toyotomi ever closer to
lord nobunaga who gave his servant the nickname
saru which wasn't exactly the most flattering
compliment in the world but then again nicknames
rarely are tsaru meant monkey and nobunaga called
toya tommy this because he had a small skinny
body and an ugly face other lords used saru as
an insult against toyotomi but he rarely took
exception to this it would not have been proper
since they outranked him but his goal was to
ensure that one day they would be the ones washing
his feet we have to presume that toyotomi fought
in most of nobunaga's conflict starting with
the battle of okazama in 1560 where the oda clan
bested hideyoshi's former master imagawa yashimoto
however he likely only fulfilled minor roles which
is why information of this period is scarce due to
a small stature it was evident that toyotomi would
not be best used as a simple rank-and-file soldier
which is why in the years that followed he was
employed for subterfuge and diplomacy which lined
up better with the hideyoshi's skill set during
that time nobunaga was warring with the saint clan
which was ruled by the young and inexperienced
sait taksiyoki he wasn't really fit to stand
in the grand shadows left by his father and
grandfather betoya tomi this was an opportunity
to gain some allies without bloodshed as he
persuaded or bribed many of saint samurais and
minor lords to switch sides to the winning team he
also oversaw the construction of sunamata castle
located on the border of the two clans to act
as a launching pad for his lord's army toyotomi
became quite adept when it came to constructing
or repairing castles although despite the popular
legend that surrounds suyamata it was not actually
built in a single night it was effective though so
when oda launched his attack on the sate clan on
september 13 1567 he conquered his enemy following
a short two-week siege of inubayama castle
for his role in the victory toyotomi was
promoted to general officially becoming one
of the oda clan's most valuable officers
all right we'll get back to today's video in just
a minute but first here's a word from today's
sponsor squarespace this is the age of creation
everyone is out there making something on the
internet you either got a great idea yourself or
you probably know someone who does and when it's
time to move that project from your head to the
screen in front of you that's where squarespace
comes in it's the perfect web tool to help you
fashion the internet into whatever you want it to
be maybe other hands-on type with lots of opinions
and ideas about what exactly your site should look
like if so very cool squarespace gives you all
the customization options you could ever want with
no updates no patches no technical beers to worry
about or maybe you just need something functional
something that works with minimal sort so you
can stay focused on the content and not the coat
of paint just use one of their quick beautiful
templates to make a website that's both fresh
and simple and once you're done setting up that
website locking in the name maybe playing around
with some of the colors there are so many extra
features that squarespace provides so that your
website can thrive email campaigns patronage
portals social integrations member only areas
analytics commercial options 24 7 customer
support really everything you need
in one place so when you're ready to get started
on the next project of yours big or small
evolves a website it's got to be with squarespace
right now you can go to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch your
new site go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save 10 of your first purchase of
a website or domain and now back to today's video
with the help of skilled generals like toyotomi
hirayoshi during the 1570s nobunaga either
subjugated or allied himself with around half of
the daimyos in japan while also marching on kyoto
and installing a shogun who acted as his puppet
it seemed like his conquest of the entire country
would only be a matter of time but nobunaga's
leadership came to a sudden halt in 1582 following
his betrayal and death at the hands of a retainer
named akichi mitsuhide with oda nobunaga out of
the picture his goal of unifying japan now fell
to his trusted retainers with toyotomi hideyoshi
leading the pack the first order of business was
to punish akichi for his treachery and avenge his
former lord by and large akechi mitsuhide's plan
was to unite the enemies of the oda clan under
his leadership and proclaim himself shogun but
he did not count on such a swift response from
hideyoshi he thought that he had picked the
time of his betrayal perfectly not only was
nobunaga defenseless but all of his retainers
were off fighting in faraway lands however as
soon as toyotomi heard of what had happened he
immediately understood that the longer he waited
the more time akechi had to consolidate his
position therefore he ended his fight against
the marie clan as fast as possible and rushed his
army to kyoto just 11 days after nobunaga's death
his betrayer and his avenger met in combat
at the battle of yamazaki concluding with
the death of akichi and the victory of toyotomi
hideyoshi once that was settled there was another
important matter to determine who would succeed
as oda nobunaga's heir toyotomi's strengthened his
actions certainly made him a viable contender
but would that be enough to persuade all the
other daimyos to pledge their allegiance to him
i think we all know the answer that of course not
for starters nobunaga had actual heirs sons and
grandsons who could carry on the odor name his
eldest son and his original heir oda nobutada had
died alongside his father but that still left two
other sons nobukatsu and nobutaka both wanted
to take over the clan toyotomi did not feel
like either son was fit to take up their father's
mantle so instead of supporting either one's claim
he instead backed oda hiranobu nobunaga's grandson
as the new leader of the clan since toyotomi was
one of the most powerful men in the faction many
others lent their support to hiranobu there was
one tiny problem though since hironobu was still
a baby when his grandfather was killed therefore
although he was the n somebody else still needed
to make all of the important decisions and
well who could that person be well why not
toyatomi hid a yoshi it was an obvious power
grab one that many other daimyos agreed with but
not quite all of them if hideyoshi wanted the
position there were a few people standing in his
way first up was shibata katsui one of nobunaga's
former generals who supported his third son oda
nobutaka as the new clan leader the two sides
fought in may 1583 at the battle of shizugatake
which ended with a decisive victory for toyotomi
shibata committed supuku following the loss while
nobataka surrendered and also killed himself a few
months later with one pretender dead this left the
other son oda nobukatsu who also didn't feel like
giving up his birthright to an infant there was
one key difference though nobukatsu had a very
powerful ally tokugawa leiasu another one of
his father's former generals if that name is
familiar to you that is because we've already
actually mentioned him as the third and final
of japan's great unifiers following nobunaga's
death tokugawa and toyotomi found themselves at
odds with each other and met in battle several
times during the mid-1580s in what became known
as the kamaki campaign however they were evenly
matched both in terms of army size and military
skill and their encounters resulted in a series
of stalemates fortunately both men were sensible
enough to realize that all they were doing was
helping out their enemies and the pyrrhic victory
of their conflict would become easy pickings for
other daimyos who were gleefully sitting back and
watching them tear each other apart therefore the
two made peace and tokugawa willingly became a
retainer of toyotomi nobokatsu did the same it
wasn't quite as willing but without tokugawa's
support he knew he had no chance of winning so
he hitched his wagon to the winning horse and one
final detail now that there was no more confusion
about who the leader was there was no point in
pretending that the oda clan was still in charge
hideyoshi went to the emperor who as we mentioned
before was a powerless figurehead and got himself
appointed kampaku which was something like a chief
counsellor or regent the imperial court then
bestowed on hidayoshi a new clan name and only
now did he actually become known as toyotomi
hideyoshi the founder of the toyotomi clan
at the time of his death nobunaga had subdued
roughly half of the provinces in japan
now that the toyotomi clan was the most powerful
faction in the country hideyoshi's purpose became
clear conquer the rest of japan this challenge was
more time consuming than anything else toyotomi
had the strongest army in japan and also benefited
from the endorsement of the imperial court which
conveyed his mission a certain air of authority
even though the emperor likely didn't have a
real choice in the matter this became toyotomi's
main preoccupation for the next five years also
starting with shikoku island in june 1585 the
clan leader invaded the island with a force of
over a hundred thousand men that kept on growing
as hiroyoshi added more provinces under his belt
the conflict was fairly one-sided and within
two months toyotomi brought the whole island
under his control afterward he extended his
dominion over the eastern half of honshu and
the southern island of kyushu by 1590 the only
real threat to hideyoshi's hegemony left in japan
was the hojo clan in the tsugami province they
were a formidable foe as they had a large army
and they were headquartered inside one of the most
secure strongholds in the country ottawa castle
but of course toyotomi went this far so he wasn't
about to stop when he was just a few feet away
from the finish line in may that year he launched
a three-month-long campaign to conquer this final
adversary it culminated with the siege of odawara
which was quite predictably where the bulk of the
hojo clan forces were concentrated however after a
few months when food and supply started to dwindle
the enemy leader hojo uyamasa committed
seppuku and his clan surrendered with his
final victory toyotomi hideyoshi accomplished
something that was once thought impossible
he unified the whole country under his rule
bringing an end to the sengoku period of japan
for the time being toyotomi's mastery of japan
was absolute but he knew just how fleeting power
could be after all his former lord was also on
his way towards achieving this goal before one
mistake ended it all for him therefore hideyoshi
enacted multiple policies that all sought to limit
the power that other people could achieve so
that they would not become threats to him he
nationalized certain industries such as silver
and gold mining to increase the country's revenue
and prevent daimyos from gaining monopolies he
conducted a great land survey and census and then
a countrywide disarmament campaign known as the
sword hunt in order to keep the peasantry content
subservient and most importantly defenseless in
the past agrarian uprisings have become a common
practice so toyotomi hoped that these measures
would deter them or at least limit the damage
they caused some of these ideas like the sword
hunt actually came from nobunaga who enacted them
first and hiroyoshi thought that they were good
enough for him to use himself another measure he
nicked from his former master was to move daimyos
around the country from their original provinces
the reasoning behind this was that if a daimyo
was in a new place the local populace would not
feel a sense of duty and obligation toward him and
were less likely to fight on his behalf hideyoshi
also imposed restrictions on marriages between
certain daimyo families so that they could not
form alliances toyotomi was also big on castles
ever since his time with the oda clan osaka castle
is probably his crowding achievement as
the majestic fortress still stands today
located in the middle of the modern city but
hideyoshi was also a prolific castle destroyer
he knew from first-hand experience how useful a
castle in the right location could be in battle
so once he was in power he didn't want them
to be used against him so he tore down his
fair share of castles lastly we should talk about
toyotomi's persecution of catholics this was still
in the very early stages of japan's relationship
with the west europeans had only arrived a few
decades prior but hideyoshi was interested in
trade so portuguese and spanish merchants were
welcome to the country however with commerce also
came christianity and toyotomi knew that religious
groups if left unchecked could become just as
dangerous and as powerful as daimyos his former
master had this problem with the buddhist movement
known as ikea so hideyoshi became very wary when
he heard that missionaries were acquiring
significant territory particularly in the
port city of nagasaki where the daimyo himself had
converted to christianity in 1587 toyotomi issued
a decree ordering all missionaries to leave the
country but it wasn't enforced since he was still
busy back then conquering the japanese provinces
it wasn't until a decade later that he passed a
new decree and this time to show he was serious
he crucified 26 christians in nagasaki who went
on to become known as the 26 martyrs of japan a
pivotal moment in the early history of japanese
catholicism ultimately though hideyoshi abandoned
his goal of ridding japan of christianity for two
reasons one he didn't want the trait to stop and
two he had his sights set on a new target korea
so far toyotomi had proven himself to be a skilled
and resourceful military leader but like many
before him he became drunk with power once japan
was under his dominion he wondered why stop at
just one country when he could have an empire he'd
looked across the water at the korean peninsula
and developed lofty ambitions of conquering not
just korea but china as well so with that in mind
in 1592 toyotomi hirayoshi sailed across the sea
of japan and invaded korea despite being blinded
by his military aspirations toyotomi did not turn
into an idiot he knew that war with korea would
likely mean war with china since the two dynasties
had close ties to each other and the former
was a tributary of the latter he also knew
that the chinese army was a lot bigger than
his but he thought he'd picked his opportunity
well because china was engaged in other major
conflicts against the mongols and several rebel
groups therefore the beginning of the war went in
toyotomi's favor throughout the year the japanese
forces successfully besieged and captured numerous
prominent korean cities such as busan pyongyang
daegu and even seoul back then called hansion it
was promising star but by the end of the war china
had managed to put out some of his own fires and
was ready to commit its army towards stopping the
japanese invasion add to that the fact that korea
still had a strong navy and the tide began to turn
in 1593 it was the allied chinese korean forces
who started laying sieges to recapture their lost
cities momentum was on their side until the second
siege of jinju which was won decisively by japan
the japanese samurai showed their viciousness in
full force here as they took no prisoners and
executed everyone inside soldiers and civilians
alike can send tens of thousands of heads back to
japan as trophies for their lord who had stayed
behind around 60 000 people were killed at the
massacre of jinju which represented the worst loss
for korea since the start of the war afterward
the two sides reached a stalemate and entered
negotiations for a peace treaty the japanese
army withdrew but talks between the two sides
weren't going so well mainly because toyotomi's
demands were in line with that of a conqueror and
china would never agree to give him what he wanted
ultimately the talks broke down completely and
japan launched its second korean invasion in
1597. this one started off worse for toyotomi
because he no longer had the element of surprise
on his side but he was also losing a second battle
one that he had no hope of ever winning that
against father time by this point hideyoshi was
in his 60s and his health had begun deteriorating
rapidly in september 1598 the ruler of japan was
on his deathbed in his castle in kyoto seemingly
regretting his decision to invade korea he died
on september 18th age 62 and his last words
were reported to be don't let my soldiers
become spirits in a foreign land this created a
tricky situation regarding his succession because
hideyoshi's son and heir toyotomi hideyori was
just five years old when his father died hideyoshi
tried to solve this issue by creating the council
of five elders consisting of five of his most
powerful daimyos who would act as regions he hoped
that this solution would prevent one man from
trying to claim power for himself but it didn't
pan out one of the five elders was tokugawa layasu
toyotomi's former foe and ally decades earlier
tokugawa agreed to seed authority to toyotomihito
yoshi for both of their benefits but he was not
about to do the same thing for some snot-nosed
five-year-old child he challenged the claim
and went to war against the toyotomi clan but
that's a story for another day so i really
hope you enjoyed today's video look if you
enjoy this sort of content we touched on a lot
of wars here then you'll really enjoy my brand
new channel war of graphics which i will link to
below and thank you for watching now just before
you leave today maybe look for something else to
watch why not check out my new channel called wara
graphics want to know all of the details about
some of history's most famous battles and wars
come join me on wara graphics from sherman's
march to the sea to operation barbarossa it's
got people fighting each other or occasionally
animals we will cover it there is a link below